キング牛丼を早く食べたことがある全国の柔ドン
ボーイたち私だ始めしっぷきんぐぎゅう道の早食いチャレンジとはなんか器給湯管と
同等の高度な抵抗なるいろんなことやっていたんですけども結構あたりはせていただき
ますと私は中の上ぐらいだということはもう分かっております o 人が早食いに対し
て優れた力が
かなりあるわけでもないんですけどもまぁ人よりちょっと高いくらいかなってぐらいだ
と思ってるんですけども
そんな私ではですね唯一唯一もだれにでも勝てるんじゃねーかってくらいの可能性が
ある礼節のキング9度にまつわるチャレンジを見つけましたそれがこちらネオキング
牛丼ちゃランチ
シャアこれしかねぇ企画の説明をしましょうまあね王キング新しいキング牛丼されると
あの女大きの緊急頓着かけているんですけども
簡単に言うと今から私しっかり音はす地獄ねマッサージを強くもうすぐ4時なんです
けどもう多分睡眠に入って5時間がれて一番なんか眠ような気がするんでルールとして
は眠るに入ってから5時間
たった頃にの目指しでもいいし人でもいいです確りと寝ているところを叩き起こして
もらってそこから一気に入れろ牛の2つ目ですね
キング旧道を食べるというタイムアタックでございますでて大きいともうすぐ減退の外
でタイマー付て阿部るっていうタイムを競うっていうタレントになっておりますここで
僕めっちゃ料理なんですなぜかと言いますとね大がめちゃくちゃ
がいいん出会え沖の良さに関しては本当に多分人類史上1位か2位ぐらい
ちょっと盛りましたねを蹴り返してはもう前年し以上50本の指には入るぐらいの速さ
だと思うんでいくらナパ扇とが早食いがすごい人でもそんなに食って断ればそれだけの
パク子を持って行ってると思うんですよその覚悟ってものです病気だとなかなか聞く後
決まらないと思う
私はその冷静な判断力は病気から守っているわけで目が覚めて覚醒する頃には
牛丼なくなっちゃってるなくらいのそういう点においてもあのかなりこの ov
早食い上を切った辺で企画は有利かなと思いますまずはあっ
俺の記録を見てくれれば
おやすみなさいじゃあおやすみなさい
眠いだろう酒はまずいつかあのヤラセなんでしないですからねぇ
今度になるからねぇ
上でプレー
[音楽]
おじさん
安住さんハイウェイー
me
re 所
power to
ございますうううううっ
rar
あれだった
あーもん持った
me
ああ
4ブルー
me
いいいいいい
mar
やばいな脳が急がない食べなきゃいけないってわかってるけど
脳が開きションっいけないして俺
[音楽]
増えるかわかんないよこれからだが地人生で一番びっくりするこれ
山やばかっ
tan
me
なんか満足じゃね10分メガ牛丼食っただけでもやばいと思うんだけどこれ
[音楽]
服はないぞ
なあああああああじゃあ
car
残念白元かもちろん本当に普通
あああああああああああああ
うわああああああ矢原いや注文さん抜きで来てですよどーするどーしよ
a
4倍の不十分敵だった
尿日の胃袋的にキングが6なるかもしれないけどたまらないと終わらないので頑張り
ます
ああああああ
me
に雲がおり
パターン
米ロ
[音楽]
あっはいああああサンズよ
4つはウォッチ開塾でこれは僕ねおぎのやさんには定評があるんで nh 報道で
いけるかなと思ったんですけど体は大丈夫でも胃袋が全くダメでした普段勤務ぎゅっと
食べるぞって構える胃袋の大きさのなんかもう半分
花の大きさだった希ガスでめちゃくちゃっつらかったですただ美味しいです最初はああ
いうわけですね
寝て起きてすぐ食べるキング弓道あのめちゃくちゃきついですまあ俺はそれでも34
だったけどなぁ
早いかがわかんないけど是非普通にきんぐぎゅうと食べるよって言う人がいたら挑戦し
てみてください
老齢に怒ってこいやー
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ